after the game they translate in
practice it is I don't say stuff just to
say it for a click you know I'm contrary
to what some may say but uh yeah I keep
receipts uh
but I'm serious I analyze and I
understand what we're up against and
what we have and what we need one thing
that I could say honestly and candidly
you better get me right now
this is the worst we're gonna be
that's somebody yeah I got Messengers
God bless him though man he's a great
coach he's done a great job God bless
him take these shots they won I don't
shoot I don't do that they won yeah I
never heard I spent no team in our
mouths gonna take shots out of the teams
bro we take the shots and keep the push
other teams just get phased and that's
posting our clips and stuff bro we don't
talk about nobody it's so funny how
everybody is focused on us like other
teams are focused on us hey bro we just
do what we do best